The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So you
guys might have heard,
we have a quiz tomorrow.
So we're going to do
a review for that.
Did everyone turn in P set six?
Yes?
Good.
All right, so
what's on this quiz?
Numerics and graph stuff.
So are there any
specific pain points?
I have problems prepared.
Now, and then at
8:00 PM is going
to be a review
session for concepts.
So now problems, 8:00 PM
concepts, tomorrow [? Yakim ?]
has office hours at
5:00 PM, conveniently
placed before the quiz.
Poor guy.
So take advantage of that.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Numerics, on
P set we were mostly
asked-- you said five,
four, whichever came before.
You mostly asked for the running
times and things like that.
But the numeric lecture
notes are kind of detailed
and go into Newtonian
method and all that.
How much detail do
we need to know?
PROFESSOR: So on the P set
we make your life easier
by giving you the
pseudocode of the code
that you needed to implement.
And we ask you one
algorithm design question,
the problem of
finding the k-th root.
And that required
you to understand
almost everything
that was going on.
We'll want you to understand
things that are going on
to come up with something fairly
similar to what you've seen.
So yeah, I know
that I told you guys
before that ignore numerics.
Just close your eyes and
pretend it didn't happen.
Actually it turns out there's a
significant amount of numerics
on the quiz.
So we're going to start
with a numerics problem,
and go through it.
I'm really sorry about that.
Clearly I didn't have
my way for this, right?
OK so we started two
big things in numerics.
Karatsuba, which is
really easy compared
to Newton which requires
a lot of understanding.
So we're going to spend
our time on Newton today.
OK, so anything aside from that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The thing we
were just talking about
before you were here
was what kind of edges
are produced by depth
first search versus breadth
first search?
AUDIENCE: And why
do they matter?
PROFESSOR: And why
do they matter.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Because it's probably
going to be a question on the--
PROFESSOR: So I'm going to
go on this very quickly now,
because I want to
cover problems,
but tonight-- this is on
the outline for the review.
So if you guys can
make it tonight--
AUDIENCE: It's late,
so I can't make it.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Well, they are also
in the lecture notes.
But I'll go through
them very quickly now.
OK, anything else?
AUDIENCE: Making trees
with DFS and BFS,
this might be tonight also.
PROFESSOR: Making trees--
AUDIENCE: Or your search trees.
So instead of-- do you
know what I mean by that?
PROFESSOR: Do you mean
graph transformation?
AUDIENCE: So you've got a tree
and you search through it.
So then when you're
searching through it,
the result of searching
it, you can put that
into almost a binary tree.
PROFESSOR: OK so
how BFS and DFS work
and how they produce
trees, I'm assuming, right?
Because if you start
out with a tree,
everything's going to be
really nice and simple.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Bidirectional search.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Is that
going to be included?
PROFESSOR: At a very
conceptual level
because we didn't give
you a P set on it.
AUDIENCE: Was that
what rubrics was?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It was bidirectional?
AUDIENCE: Well it's not going
to be on it so, we're happy.
PROFESSOR: Well I mean
we didn't give you--
you kind of had to solve a
problem just by-- we have
to tell you this
is bidirectional
BFS, go code it up.
This is bi-directional
Dijkstra, go code it up.
So we're not going to ask you
anything too fancy on them.
So nothing past the P set.
AUDIENCE: Will you
have a question
like when you were
studying BFS, saying
how there will be
levels of graphs?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Could there
be anything about that?
PROFESSOR: So levels of graphs
as in the levels in BFS?
Or the levels that we're using
when we're building graphs?
AUDIENCE: Copies of
graphs and then--
AUDIENCE: Transformations.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
OK, transformations and layers.
Yeah, I think this is important.
AUDIENCE: Any particular tips
on what kind of transformations
we might encounter?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Problem one has this
transformation, problem two--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Basically,
when do we use these?
Is it when we are given more
than one parameter for a cause.
PROFESSOR: So I have
some problems on this
but we have to have a deal.
You guys have to help me
go through the problems
fast enough so that we get here.
OK?
So if you know the
answer, say the answer.
Don't let me wait.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Also, when you run
Dijkstra and Bellman-Ford
on a graph, with
positive edges, they
produce the same
shortest path weight
but might have different trees?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
that's conceivable.
Because they--
AUDIENCE: It's one of the
questions on spring 2011.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So first off, they both
have positive edges, so
they both work, right?
If you had to choose,
which one would you choose?
If you had to choose
which are going to run,
which one would you run?
AUDIENCE: Dijkstra.
PROFESSOR: OK, why Dijkstra?
AUDIENCE: It's faster.
PROFESSOR: Faster.
OK so positive edges,
Dijkstra is faster.
Now if you're going
to run both of them,
they relax edges in
different orders.
Right?
So let's say we have this.
I know you guys remember the
sequence of diamonds, right?
My nice example that shows that
the number of paths in a graph
is exponential in the
number of vertices.
So let's have one diamond.
1, 1, 1, 1.
S, A, B, T. So say we're
looking for shortest path
from S. Right?
So the distance
from S to S is zero,
and everything else
starts out as infinity.
SA is infinity.
SB is infinity.
ST is infinity.
Suppose I relax
edges in this order.
One, two, three, four.
What am I going to get?
If I relax SA, then the
distance from S to A
is going to become 1, right?
Because it's 0 plus 1 1.
And then the parent
of A is going to be S.
Now say I relax AT.
The distance from S
to T is going to be 2.
Sorry.
Parent of T is going
to be A. Right?
OK now I'm relaxing this one.
This is going to become
one and the parent of B
is going to become S. And
as I'm relaxing this one,
nothing happens because I
already had a distance of 2.
Now if I relax them
in this order instead,
so the bottom one first and
the top one is afterwards,
I'm going to get
the different path.
Right?
OK so what path do I
have now from S to T?
AUDIENCE: Right
now you have SAT.
PROFESSOR: OK, why SAT?
How do you compute the path?
Parent pointers, right?
Start at T, look at
the parent pointer.
Look at the parent pointer.
So because I relax
them in this order,
this path was considered
before this path.
So the parent pointer of
T is A but if I relax them
in the other order, the
parent pointer could be B.
So by the way, this
could happen if you're
running Dijkstra
or Bellman-Ford.
Or if you're running
Dijkstra, it's
just about how you're going
to have the ties separated.
So your priority
queue implementation
might give you different paths.
Does it make sense now?
So if the order in
which edges are relaxed.
That's what defines with path
you're going to end up with.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Hopefully useful.
All right.
I saw four hands before.
AUDIENCE: Oh, just
overall, how similar
is this test compared
to previous tests?
PROFESSOR: Less algorithm
design, more concepts.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Well OK,
not less algorithm--
so it's not going to be as
much out-of-the-box thinking,
it's going to be a lot more
of what we drilled already.
So as a hint, what
kind of problem
did we practice over,
and over, and over?
AUDIENCE: States
PROFESSOR: OK.
Graph transformation, right?
So chances are you'll see that.
AUDIENCE: Wait, what's
graph transformation?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So we start
with a complicated problem
and reduce it to a shortest path
problem or to a shortest length
path problem.
OK.
Cool.
So that being said, let's go.
Numerics, everyone's
favorite topic.
So suppose we're
trying to compute this.
Cube root of 6,006.
And the problem
statement says this,
you start out with an
initial approximation of one,
and it wants two
approximations after that.
The problem also tells you which
function we're going to use.
But why don't we
make this fun and try
to guess what the
function will be?
AUDIENCE: x cubed minus 6,006?
PROFESSOR: OK. x
cubed minus 6,006
why did I choose this function?
Well, not me.
Why did you choose
this function?
AUDIENCE: It's the root.
PROFESSOR: OK so reason
number one-- right?
Important.
Has to be zero at the
answer, because that's
what Newton's method gives us.
And what else?
AUDIENCE:
Multiplication is easy.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So it's easy to compute
whatever Newton's method wants
us to compute.
What does Newton's method
want us to compute?
So given an approximation,
xi, how do we
get to the next
approximation, xi plus 1.
Formula.
By the way, this formula
should be on your cheat sheets.
If it's not, no
sympathy for you.
AUDIENCE: I don't remember.
xi plus f over f prime.
AUDIENCE: Where's the prime?
AUDIENCE: Prime's on the bottom.
PROFESSOR: So yeah,
where's the prime?
And is this right?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
there a constant?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it minus?
PROFESSOR: Isn't it minus?
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
AUDIENCE: There you go.
PROFESSOR: So yeah,
if you guys start out
with the wrong formula
you'd get the wrong answer.
Again, no sympathy.
So get that on your sheets.
OK so this is what we
need to compute, right?
You start with an approximation
and you have to subtract this.
So this has to be
easy to compute.
What if I chose instead
a very nice function.
x-- sorry, x minus.
This is clearly zero where
I want it to be, right?
AUDIENCE: But we
don't know what six--
PROFESSOR: But if
I'm trying to compute
the successive approximations,
very good, I'm getting what?
f of x over f prime of x is
x minus square root 3 6,006
over-- what's the
derivative of this?
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: One.
So I haven't done
anything, right?
In order to compute the
successive approximation,
I have to know this number.
So this doesn't get me anywhere,
that's why it's a bad function.
By the way, it's not enough
that this is easy to compute.
What you want is this guy
has to be easy to compute.
In the case of division,
we had a function
that looked pretty wacky.
But then when we divided
that by the derivative,
we got something
reasonably nice.
So this has to be
easy to compute.
AUDIENCE: So we changed it
from that one to this one just
because this one is easier or--
PROFESSOR: So we're
using this one
because this one-- let's see
how easy this one is to compute.
Computing this one requires
that you know the answer
to your original problem,
which is not cool.
Right.
So you're trying to
compute this number.
But if you use this,
Newton's approximation
requires that you compute this.
So you have to know this here.
Which is what you're trying
to do in the first place.
AUDIENCE: Wait, I'm confused.
We went from x
cubed minus 6 over 6
to x minus cube
root of 6 over 6.
So what's your--
PROFESSOR: So this
is a good function.
We can use this.
This is a bad function
and I was asking
why is this a bad function.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So lets see, if we try
to compute it using this,
what do we get?
xi minus
AUDIENCE: x cubed minus 6,006.
PROFESSOR: X cubed minus 6,006.
Divided by--
AUDIENCE: 3x cubed.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So someone simplify this for me.
AUDIENCE: 6i minus x over 3
plus 6,006 over 3 squared.
Oh, well.
It's 2,002.
PROFESSOR: I'll
choose the easy step.
OK.
So what's x1?
AUDIENCE: You plug in x0.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I heard a 2,002.
I don't think it's--
it's very close.
AUDIENCE: 2,002 and two thirds.
0.67.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
So 0.67, let's
get to that later.
I don't like fractional numbers.
I mean this is the
right answer math-wise,
but we'll get to that because
if we want to code this up,
we probably don't want
fractional numbers.
So very good point there.
What if I want to compute x2?
I take this guy and
I plug it into where?
This thing over here, right?
So this way I can
compute approximations
that get closer and closer
to my original value.
OK.
Does this ring a bell?
Yes, everyone is
happy with this?
Cool.
So how about the initial guess?
Here we started with
a known initial guess.
Is this a good guess?
AUDIENCE: It's a
really bad guess.
2,002?
PROFESSOR: No, I mean 1.
AUDIENCE: 1?
That's also a really bad guess.
AUDIENCE: Why
would you even ask?
AUDIENCE: 11 and a half.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So you're saying 11 and a
half would be a nice guess.
So, first off, let's
see, what do we
need to-- what does Newton's
algorithm guarantee?
What-- if the guess
is really, really bad,
would we get an
answer all the time?
Maybe takes forever but
we'll get an answer.
True or false?
AUDIENCE: True.
PROFESSOR: Not true.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: But it has to be
right for your answer to be--
PROFESSOR: OK, so what does
Newton's method guarantee?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yep, yep.
So what is the fancy
math name for that?
AUDIENCE: Quadratic
convergence or something.
PROFESSOR: Quadratic
convergence, all right.
So this is what
Newton guarantees.
Quadratic-- so what
does this mean?
For all your approximations,
they're all going to be xi.
If we write them as true
answer times 1 plus error, i.
So this error is the relative
error of the approximation.
Newtons method guarantees
that the error at each step
is squared.
So if this guy-- if
E0 is greater than 1,
would we get an answer?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: OK so what we need?
What's the minimum that we need?
E0 has to be between
what and what?
AUDIENCE: Negative 1?
AUDIENCE: Is it negative
1, 1 or 0 and 1?
AUDIENCE: It would
be 0 and 1, right?
Because won't it
be less than one?
AUDIENCE: Negative 1.
AUDIENCE: Oh, absolute value.
PROFESSOR: I think if you
score something smaller
than negative 1
you get a positive
and then-- so, let's
say this works.
So then x0 has to be
between what and what
in relation to the real answer?
AUDIENCE: The real answer
minus x0 over [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: 2 times the
actual answer is 0.
PROFESSOR: OK so this
is a sucky guess.
We can do a lot
better, but at least it
will make the thing converge.
Fair enough?
OK now what if I
want a good guess?
First off, let's backtrack
to a more general problem
because this is easy, right?
To plug it into our calculator
and you have the answer.
So what if I'm trying to
compute cube root of r.
Can everyone see, by the way?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Mhmm.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I'm trying to
compute cube root of r.
r is a number.
Suppose I'm trying to compute,
for example, cube root of 2.
What's the first
thing I need to do?
I'm going to code
this up, by the way.
Well, not me but suppose
we want to code this up.
What's the first
thing we want to do?
AUDIENCE: I think we want an
initial guess at a function.
PROFESSOR: OK so we're going
to need an initial guess.
That's good.
And what else do we want?
AUDIENCE: We need to decide
how much precision we want.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because this
cube root of 2 is 1.
If you round down.
That doesn't tell us very much.
I don't know, we don't
like the fractions.
PROFESSOR: We don't
like fractions.
OK, why don't we like fractions?
It's a lot easier to code.
AUDIENCE: Decimal point there.
PROFESSOR: Yep, you have to
deal with the decimal point
and we don't like that.
So we want to take
this problem, and we
want to move it
into integer land.
So what we did
here has fractions.
We don't like that because
that's a pain to code.
We didn't make you code
fractions on the P set, right?
So then we better know
how to avoid fractions
if you want to solve
real life problems.
So we're going to say that
we're happy with some amount
of precision in the answer.
And then we're going
to do something
that lets us do all our
computations in integer land.
Because that's a happy place.
So how do I-- suppose
I'm working in base B
and I want d digits
of precision.
What do I want to compute?
How do I transform the
problem in that way?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You multiply 2
root 3 times B to the d.
PROFESSOR: OK so
we want the answer
to be 2 times B to the d.
And if we're integer land, what
are we actually going to get?
So suppose B is 10-- let's work
with familiar numbers-- d is 2.
So we're going to
want to compute
square root of 3 2 times 100.
Does anyone have a
calculator and can tell me
what square root of 3 is?
First two digits?
AUDIENCE: Cube root of 2.
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
cube root of 2.
AUDIENCE: 1.2.
PROFESSOR: So let's say that
square root of 3 is 1.2345.
Hopefully someone will
fix this up for us.
But let's say it's this.
If I multiply it by
100 what do I get?
123 times 45.
So multiply by 100 means
you move the decimal point
to the right.
Right?
So it's still not an integer.
If we work in integer
land, our algorithm
will return an integer.
What's the integer
that we're hoping
our algorithm will return?
AUDIENCE: 1.23, right?
PROFESSOR: We're
hoping so, right?
Why?
What can you do with 123?
Shift right.
So if you divide this
by 100, you get 1.23.
And this is our answer with
two digits of precision.
AUDIENCE: Do you want
the actual-- it's 1.2599.
PROFESSOR: You guys are good.
OK.
So our algorithm will
give us this, right?
So it's not going to
give us exactly cube
root of 2 times 100.
It's not going to give
us exactly this value.
What's it going to give us?
AUDIENCE: Two digits--
close to that.
PROFESSOR: So it's going to
give us an integer, right?
So what kind of integer?
Math.
AUDIENCE: Truncated?
PROFESSOR: OK, what's
the math for that?
Truncated.
Floor.
Very good.
So this is what we're
actually going to compute.
Actually, because
we're in integer land,
we're going to have
floors at every step
when we're doing
that approximation.
And there's a fancy
proof for Newton
that says that even though
you're taking floors
all the time, it will still
converge to the right thing.
So in order to compute
this, how are we
going to transform the problem?
AUDIENCE: Slide
the Bd into that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: You're going to
have to put a 3 in there.
B to the 3d.
PROFESSOR: So we're
actually going
to compute cube root
of 2 times B to the 3d.
Fair enough?
And if we slide this
right by the digits
afterwards we're going to get
our two digits of precision.
OK.
So now I figured
out my precision.
I want an initial guess--
and actually I lied,
there's one more problem.
Running time.
Do you guys want to start
with the running time
or initial guess?
AUDIENCE: Initial guess.
PROFESSOR: OK so what I
want a good initial guess?
AUDIENCE: Between 0 and 2x.
PROFESSOR: OK so if I don't
have that the algorithm will
crash and burn.
When we did Newton
in recitation,
I said that I would
like two things.
And I backed up, I coded
that into P set five
when I did the guess.
So what are the
two things that I
want from a good initial guess?
AUDIENCE: Order of magnitude?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Perfect.
AUDIENCE: Oh, god.
[LAUGHS]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
order of magnitude
is a fancy CSE way to say,
right number of digits.
Suppose we're computing this.
Or suppose we're
computing the cube
root of some number
in base B. So
supposed r is somewhere
between 0 and B.
It's one digit in base
B. How many digits
is this result is going to have?
AUDIENCE: The amount
of digits divided by 3.
The amount of digits
in 2 times B to the 3d.
Which is whatever
B to the 3d is.
AUDIENCE: D plus 1?
PROFESSOR: OK so roughly
either d or d plus 1.
See, d plus 1.
So a decent approximation would
be a 1 followed by these zeros.
An even better
approximation is what
if we can get the first
digit right or almost right?
How would we do that?
AUDIENCE: Pick up the
first digit of our r
PROFESSOR: OK and I promise
that r is one digit.
Just So let's say we pick up r.
And?
AUDIENCE: We do
Newtons method on that.
And we just guess one?
Is that a thing?
PROFESSOR: Uhh--
AUDIENCE: Take the
cube root of it.
AUDIENCE: It should be
some kind of inefficient--
PROFESSOR: Yeah what's some
kind of inefficient way
that we can think of quickly?
AUDIENCE: Can you--
AUDIENCE: Binary?
PROFESSOR: Did you
say divide and--
AUDIENCE: --divide it by 2r?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
I thought You were>you
were going to say divide
and conquer.
So I heard binary search,
so binary search wins.
So we're going to
the binary search.
Binary search from 0 to r.
Right?
In order to the binary search,
suppose I have my guess,
g, I want to see how g
compares to cube root of r.
How do I do this?
So this is equivalent to
g cubed compared to r.
g cubed is to multiplication,
so I know how to do that.
OK?
Make sense for everyone?
Sorry, r.
My bad.
So this is going to be one
digit in base, B, so hopefully
not too much work.
OK.
But remember this, you can;t
do the comparison directly
because you can't
compute this directly.
So you need to do it this way.
AUDIENCE: So r is just the
first digit of the number?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So we're going for a
slightly easier problem.
We're trying to compute the cube
root of a single digit number
to an arbitrary precision.
You can make it harder, but
there's no point right now.
So we'll stick to this.
So how much time will this take?
How many approximations
will I need to do?
By the way, so suppose I
compute my approximations.
Right?
So I compute x0, x1, x2,
x3, so on and so forth.
When do I stop?
AUDIENCE: When both
digits are the same?
PROFESSOR: All the
digits are the same.
So when one approximation is
the same with the next one.
That's what you're?
Right.
So these are all integers.
The moment I get two
identical integers,
I know there's no point
to continue because I'm
going to get the
same value forever.
Also this means
that Newton's method
has converged on this integer.
So hopefully I will
get the answer,
which I can convert
into the right answer.
OK so how fast does this work?
What is n?
When am I going to stop?
AUDIENCE: Log base 2 of d?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So n is-- so the number of
digits in my approximation--
the number of correct
digits-- doubles every time.
So after log these steps,
I have the right answer.
Now what if instead of doing
this I did binary search?
So instead of doing Newton's
method I do binary search on 0
to r?
I can do that, right?
Because I can get
a guess and then
I can use this to see if
my guess is right or wrong.
So in theory I could
do it in binary search.
How fast would that be?
AUDIENCE: And what
is the difference
between big r and little r?
PROFESSOR: Big R is-- oh,
I didn't write the big r.
Big r is this guy, here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, gotcha.
OK.
PROFESSOR: And this is little r.
Sorry.
Good question, I
apologize for that.
So R is little r
times B to the 3d.
AUDIENCE: D times log 2 of B--
AUDIENCE: To the d.
Log r to the d.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's
the same thing.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
On the y.
PROFESSOR: OK so the
number of guesses is
AUDIENCE: Log big r.
PROFESSOR: Log big r.
And someone was one step ahead
and said it's order of B times
log little r.
Or I think it's d plus little r.
So this is order of d.
Does this make
sense for everyone?
AUDIENCE: I didn't quite
follow what happened there.
PROFESSOR: So I'm doing a
binary search on the range
from 0 to r.
How many steps?
How many guesses?
Log r.
Right?
This is binary search.
R is little r times b to the 3d.
So if we log this,
log R is log little r
plus 3d log B. B is order
one, so we get order of log B.
OK so Newton's method
is exponentially faster
in terms of the number of digits
compared to binary search.
So if you can pull it
off with Newton's method
and you have big
numbers, you probably
want to use Newton's method.
Because binary search will
give you a slower algorithm.
OK, how are we doing
with these concepts?
I see everyone's unhappy.
Is it because of Newton
or something I said?
AUDIENCE: Can you
summarize the difference
between binary search
and Newton's, again?
So you said binary
search takes kind
of long versus Newton's method.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how do you do binary search?
AUDIENCE: Divide and
conquer, which is--
PROFESSOR: Divide
and conquer, right?
You start out with an interval,
you guess somewhere in half,
and then you see which half of
the interval you recurse onto.
And your interval halves
in size every time.
So given the initial size of the
interval, the number of guesses
you have is log of
that interval size.
In this case we're guessing
a number between 0 and r.
So the big goal is to
compute cube root of R.
And we're guessing that
hey, it has to be somewhere
between 0 and R. So we're going
to do binary search on this.
And in order to see
how our guess compares,
we're going to use
this trick, here.
So the number of guesses
we make is log R. Now
R is that number, over there.
It's little r times B to the 3d.
So how many digits does it have?
Roughly d digits.
So log of R is
going to be order d.
OK so if you do binary search
to guess a d digit number,
the running time will
be roughly order d.
Order of the number of digits.
If you use Newton's
method and your function
is good and
everything converges,
then you have
quadratic convergence.
Which guarantees that you'll
have log of d guesses.
Log of d approximations.
So Newton's method is a
lot faster for big numbers,
because you have a log
there instead of d.
So this is the big
difference between them.
But for Newton, you
need a lot of things.
Right?
You need that function,
you need an initial guess,
you need a lot of
things to make it work.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is that just like
the number of times it runs?
Because don't you have a
multiplication and a division?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So this is the
number of guesses.
The total running time
is quite different.
You need to jump through a few
more hoops to analyze that.
But this is the number of
guesses or approximations
that each method makes.
So if your math
would be order one,
this would be the running time.
If the math isn't order one,
then it gets more complicated.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
running time of a division?
PROFESSOR: What is running
time of the division using
Newton's method?
It's the same as the running
time of the multiplication
that you're using to
compute your approximations.
And it's like two pages
of notes to prove that.
So let's not go over that now.
But the idea is that every
time you're multiplying,
you start multiplying
small numbers
and the numbers double in size
when you're multiplying them.
So only the last
multiplication counts.
All the others are
tiny compared to that.
OK.
Anything else about Newton?
Sorry guys, we have
Newton on the exam
so we have to go through this.
Let's go through some
fun graph problems.
OK so we kicked off these two.
Graphs the BFS edges and
graph transformations.
OK I'm going to do a
graph transformation first
because I think that's
more useful than BFS edges,
but hopefully I'm
going to get to both.
So suppose I have a graph.
Each path is either red or blue.
By the way, no political
connection whatsoever.
And you have weights
on each path.
So we want a path from S to T
with the following constraint.
So these weights are
the costs of, maybe,
how much gas you're
spending to go on that road.
So in order to switch from
a red edge to a blue edge,
you also have to pay some money.
You have to pay a cost of 5.
So if you're going
to go-- if you're
going to go from S
to A-- let's call
this guy A-- if you're
going to go this way,
then your total cost is 3, 1, 4.
If you're going to go from S
to B, then if you go this way,
your total cost is
going to be 3 plus 1
plus 5 for switching from
a red to a blue edge.
So the cost for switching
from red to blue is 5.
The cost for switching
from blue to red is 5.
And I'll let you guys
think of it for a bit
while I erase the board.
AUDIENCE: What's your goal in
playing the best path from--
PROFESSOR: Best path from S
to T. Smallest total cost.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So any thoughts?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's
kind of on the run,
but create a supernode
connect all the red paths.
And create another one
connecting all the blue paths.
And then try to find the
shortest length to T just using
those two graphs, I guess.
PROFESSOR: So you're
going to create
a supernode
connecting the paths.
So how does this work?
AUDIENCE: You create
the path from S
to T just using the reds.
PROFESSOR: OK so I'm going
to copy everything and use
the reds.
So S, C, D, T, and I'm
only going to use the reds.
All right, red, red, red.
OK.
AUDIENCE: And then-- wait,
is that all the right paths?
PROFESSOR: I hope so.
AUDIENCE: All right,
and then you're
going to try doing that
with the blue paths as well.
PROFESSOR: So am I creating
another copy of this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's see, what else, what else?
OK
AUDIENCE: From S to T, right?
PROFESSOR: A path from S to T?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so you
just compare the path of S
to the path of T.
So you completely
take that out, the
additional cost [INAUDIBLE]
just by comparing
those two and seeing
which ones are
the shortest path.
AUDIENCE: It's correct
for this graph,
but it's not correct in general.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: And the last
option would be combining--
PROFESSOR: OK so if
I do this so far.
So I've taken the original graph
and I've created two copies.
One that has all
of the red paths,
one that has all the blue paths.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: By the
way, let's label this.
The nodes are--
AUDIENCE: So it would
work in this specific case
because you [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if you compute
the two shortest paths here,
you'll get the path using only
reds, path using only blues.
But you're not
expressing the fact
that you're allowed to alternate
between reds and blues.
How do you express that?
AUDIENCE: Make a
lot of corrections.
AUDIENCE: Put two layers in--
PROFESSOR: Two layers.
OK so these are two layers.
This is the red layer, and
this is the blue layer.
And how do I connect them?
AUDIENCE: If there's
an edge connecting them
on the upper graph, we're
just connecting them.
AUDIENCE: Or connect
the respective nodes
and make it a 5.
PROFESSOR: Both
answers work, they
have the same number of edges.
The last answer is
easier to visualize,
so I'm going to go with that.
So I can go from the red
world to the blue world,
and back, if I'm
willing to pay 5.
So this is what--
AUDIENCE: And you just use
those with the new edges.
Or not DFS, but Dijkstra's.
PROFESSOR: All right so all the
edges here are positive, right?
So I'm going to use Dijkstra.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
case in a positive graph
that Dijkstra's slower
than Bellman-Ford?
Because one is like b log b,
and the other one is like b e.
Right?
So if you have a lot of--
PROFESSOR: OK so
what is Dijkstra?
AUDIENCE: B log b-
PROFESSOR: Almost.
AUDIENCE: T log
b, I think, right?
That's the theoretical
best case ever,
PROFESSOR: So actually,
the theoretical is E plus--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that's what I meant.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Oh--
PROFESSOR: This is what
you get with heaps,
so this is what we
got in the P set.
AUDIENCE: What
was the first one?
AUDIENCE: The first one
is like Fibonacci heaps.
It's got a really
high constant factor,
so you never actually use it.
PROFESSOR: So this is a
nice theoretical thing,
and this is what
you get in practice.
If you use the
regular binary heaps.
And so you compare
this to Bellman-Ford
which is-- whoops--
V times E. I'm
going to guess that this
is faster no matter what.
AUDIENCE: Yes, OK.
So the theoretical one could
be slower, then, possible.
The Fibonacci one?
Because if you have a ton of
vertices without many edges.
PROFESSOR: OK If you
have a ton of vertices
but not too many edges.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Then you're
saying that this
is going to be bigger than--
so what do you do in that case?
AUDIENCE: I mean you could just
ignore the vertices, I guess.
PROFESSOR: OK so if
you have a ton of
vertices and not
that many edges.
So if you have edges
smaller-- sorry-- yeah,
it's just smaller
than vertices, then
some vertices have
to be unconnected.
So what to do?
AUDIENCE: You just ignore them.
AUDIENCE: You're not going
to reach them anyway.
PROFESSOR: How do
you ignore them?
How do you ignore them in--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see your point.
So you're never going
to get to them anyways.
So--
AUDIENCE: Well no, but
once you've started at one,
you're going to have
to touch them all.
They're all going
to be in the heap.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: No, don't
put them in the heap
until you look at them.
AUDIENCE: Well, there's
a starting point, right?
If you can't go anywhere in the
starting point, you're done.
PROFESSOR: OK so you take the
starting point and you do--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Ok so I would take
the starting point and do a BFS
and ignore everything else.
And that is clearly order of
how many vertices and edges that
are reachable from that.
So that will give
you a nice graph.
Either that, or if you
initialization your Dijkstra
carefully enough, this
actually only reflects
the reachable
edges and vertices.
So you never have this.
So either one works.
In theory mode, it might be
better to say I'll do a BFS
and reduce the graph.
Because that's easier to argue.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, for
this, when you make all
that-- I guess my
question is are we
going to be asked to
talk about running times
for different transformation?
Or the algorithms?
PROFESSOR: Well so at
the very least, last time
we said, this is the problem.
Give us an algorithm
with this running time.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So you have
to be able to know
your transformations.
So not the running for
computing the transformation,
but you have to be able to know
how much bigger the graph gets
and what that implies
for the running time.
Turns out that usually
for these transformations
you can compute
them in linear time.
So the time for computing
a transformation
is much smaller than
the time for running
Dijkstra or Bellman-Ford.
So that's why we don't
really go into that.
This one is definitely
linear time.
So what happens to the
graph in this case?
Number of edges and
number of vertices.
AUDIENCE: Number of
edges increases by V
and number of vertices.
So increase by V.
PROFESSOR: That's
V, and times is 2.
So you plug this into
Bellman-Ford or Dijkstra,
you find out the
new running time.
So every time you see what is
the size of your new graph,
and you plug that
into the algorithm.
OK so what is the
intuition behind this?
Did everyone get this problem?
So it's the old problem
that we're going through
again and again, where you
have a graph that's 2D,
and we want to compute
something that Dijkstra
can't compute on it's own.
Or that Bellman-Ford
So in order to be able
to compute those things,
we need to add additional
states to the graph.
And the way we do that is
we make copies of the graph
that we call layers.
Because we're thinking that if
you take that 2D map, and you
create copies of
it, you basically
have a 3D graph where there
is the original graph.
That's the science part
of the problem, the art
part of solving the
problem is figuring out
what those layers are
and how you connect them.
Because by doing that you
can solve a ton of problems,
as we have seen in this class.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
possibility that you
have a very large
number of layers needed
to be permutations
of-- different choice
to make instead of
just a red or a blue?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So is there a problem where
we had a ton of layers?
AUDIENCE: Mhmm.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
OK so two problems, right?
AUDIENCE: One for every second.
[LAUGHS]
PROFESSOR: And so these
are the layers, presumably.
We had two problems that
had a ton of layers.
One of them was
the highway problem
where you had timetables.
And there, the number
of layers was the number
of minutes in the day
you're considering.
So roughly, 1440.
And the other one was StarCraft
where the number of layers
was something ginormous, right?
So as long as that fits
the theory, that's fine.
As long as the number of layers
fits whatever the problem wants
you to compute, its OK.
AUDIENCE: So transforming
another layer,
is that like in V time because
copying the number of vertices?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so you should be
able to implement this in
order of V plus E, which
is what you need to output
the new graph description.
I claim that for this you can.
AUDIENCE: So for E prime, I
guess, how'd you get that?
PROFESSOR: So for
each vertex you
are going to create a
red copy and a blue copy.
2V, this is easy.
Now, the red edges stay in here,
the blue edges stay in here.
So nothing changed so far.
But each red vertex needs to
be connected to the blue vertex
by an edge of weight 5.
So that means that we're going
to copy over the original edges
and we're going to add the
edges that connect the vertices.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So we're not going
to ask about the running
time of the
transformations in general.
Because we assume that they
can be done in linear time.
But you need to at least have a
sense of whether your graph is
going to double,
whether it's going
to increase exponentially, or
what's going to happen to it.
So let's make a small
tweak to this problem.
Suppose that the
instead of having this,
I can go from red to
blue, but once I've
gone from red to
blue, I can't go back.
So I can start out either red
or blue, I can go red to blue,
but once I'm in blue I
can't go back to red.
AUDIENCE: Make those
directed edges.
PROFESSOR: From where to where?
AUDIENCE: Red to blue.
PROFESSOR: OK so this is
how I express constraints,
in constraints among layers.
Before, we had two
layers, red and blue.
And we connected them by
an edge of weight 5, which
says you can go from
red world to blue world,
and back, all you
have to do is pay 5.
If we have directed edges,
then this is a constraint.
If the constraint
said there's no cost,
but you can only go
from red to blue,
you still have to do two layers.
And keep track of
which layer you're in.
But then your edge
of the weight 0.
Since we have to pay,
the edge is weight 5.
So we can use layers to
express additional costs,
or just to express constraints.
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: Does this include
back edges, or forward edges,
as well?
PROFESSOR: Let's get to that.
OK, so does this
make sense so far?
One more question, what shortest
path do I want to compute here?
To make sure that
you guys got it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you have to
do two of them maybe, four--
PROFESSOR: OK, I
like four of them.
So I have to do SR, TR,
SR, TB, SB, TR, SB, TB.
Fortunately, our
algorithms give us
the shortest path
from one source
to all of the other vertices.
So I'd only have to run
Dijkstra or Bellman-Ford twice.
What if I want to run
the algorithm once?
What do I do?
AUDIENCE: You put
vertices on the edges.
PROFESSOR: OK so supernode
as a source, supernode
as a destination.
And I connect them to what?
AUDIENCE: Zero weight.
PROFESSOR: To?
AUDIENCE: The two.
AUDIENCE: Final V.
PROFESSOR: OK, very good.
And?
AUDIENCE: Same.
PROFESSOR: So what
happened here?
This says you can go anywhere.
And this says you can
come back from anywhere.
AUDIENCE: Bridge
between the worlds.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: So do we want this
to be directed or undirected,
by the way, does it matter?
AUDIENCE: Directed.
You can only go one way--
AUDIENCE: Oh, depends on which
problem you're talking about.
PROFESSOR: I think if
they're undirected,
it shouldn't matter too
much, because there shouldn't
be a path where you go back to
the source and then you switch.
But this would be
if you're on a quiz
and you don't want
to think about
that, I'd make them directed
just to be on the safe side.
AUDIENCE: What were
the four shortest
paths you said we
needed to calculate
for the original problem,
before you added the supernodes?
PROFESSOR: So we don't
know whether we start out
with a red edge--
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: --with a blue edge.
We don't know whether we end up
with a red edge or a blue edge.
AUDIENCE: Stay in red
world, stay in blue world,
red to blue and blue to red.
PROFESSOR: Yeah OK, cool.
So let's talk about BFS and
DFS very briefly, I guess.
So BFS and DFS.
What does BFS give us?
Why is it useful?
AUDIENCE: Shortest paths.
PROFESSOR: Shortest
paths in terms
of number of edges, right?
No weight on the engines.
So shortest paths using
the number of edges.
What does DFS give us?
AUDIENCE: Topological start.
PROFESSOR: Hey, man, you
had this on the P set,
I wouldn't call it nothing.
OK, how does BFS
look at the graph?
How does it partition the graph?
Nodes are grouped into--
AUDIENCE: Levels.
PROFESSOR: Levels.
AUDIENCE: The light
distance and the source.
PROFESSOR: So you
start with a source,
and then all the nodes
that are one edge
away are at level one,
all the nodes that
are two edges away are level
two, so on and so forth.
What does DFS give us?
A mess?
A mess, right?
So it gives us edge types.
And it gives us exit times.
Exit times are useful for
topological sort, right?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It also
gives us a tree.
PROFESSOR: OK, does
BFS give us a tree?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes, they
both give us trees.
PROFESSOR: So both of
them will give us trees.
So what are those trees?
For each node, BFS or
DFS discovered that node
by going from some parent
node across an edge.
So that edge belongs to
the BFS or to the DFS tree.
How do we compute those trees?
AUDIENCE: Just do it?
PROFESSOR: So how do
you, in BFS and DFS,
what do you compute to--
AUDIENCE: Parent pointers?
PROFESSOR: Parent pointers.
So that's what you use
to keep track of them.
Sorry the question
is bad but that's
what I want you
to get out of it.
Parent pointers.
So DFS and BFS will both
compute trees of the graph.
Are they the same trees
or different trees?
AUDIENCE: Probably different.
PROFESSOR: Different
trees, right?
Let's take this.
S, A, B, right?
BFS will give us this,
DFS will give us this.
OK, what edge types
do we have in DFS?
AUDIENCE: Forward edges.
PROFESSOR: OK, forward.
Cool.
What are they?
AUDIENCE: Those are
just from parent
to children that
are being presented.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So, I don't
know how else to put it.
PROFESSOR: OK so you should
have this on your cheat sheet,
right?
If nobody knows the
answer, you should have it
on your cheat sheet.
So tree edges, the ones that
show up in the DFS tree.
Backwards edges,
AUDIENCE: Cross edges.
PROFESSOR: Cross edges.
AUDIENCE: Forward edges.
PROFESSOR: And forward edges.
If your graph is undirected,
what types of edges
do you not have?
AUDIENCE: Forward edges.
Forward edges and
backward edges.
Or no, forward edges.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is a lecture
notes, and we're
going to go over them tonight.
But if you can't make it,
they're in lecture notes.
So you should have this
on your cheat sheet
if you don't know them.
Right?
Nobody answered today, so
if you guys don't have them
on your cheat sheet
I will be upset.
OK.
Cool.
More questions?
AUDIENCE: Edges do not
exist in BFS, edge types?
PROFESSOR: DFS uses-- so
out of BFS we get levels,
and out DFS we get
those edge types.
AUDIENCE: Is there--
about the edge types?
PROFESSOR: Some algorithms
use them in their proofs.
So the proof for
topological sort
uses the fact that in
directed acyclic graphs,
you won't have some
types of edges.
For the other types
of edges it argues
that the order that you
get from topological sort
is the right order.
So it's mostly theoretical
but since we taught you
about edge types, we
might ask you about them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So does
DFS actually-- is
it able to distinguish
between back-crossing over,
or is it only-- does it only
see that the node has already
been visited by something?
PROFESSOR: So how would you make
it distinguish between them?
You have to, right?
Because otherwise, why
are we studying them?
There has to be a way to
distinguish between them.
AUDIENCE: Because the
DFS does recursive calls
and you know where the back is.
PROFESSOR: So let's
do a DFS tree quickly.
So suppose we went like this.
And then like this,
this, and then this.
Sorry, I'm trying really hard to
make up an example on the spot
such that I won't
discount myself.
How do I get that, do you know?
AUDIENCE: Maybe an edge
from the second one
to the last one on the right.
PROFESSOR: Here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah and this
will be the arrowhead,
and you can start
from the second one.
PROFESSOR: This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Wouldn't that be a forward edge?
PROFESSOR: OK
AUDIENCE: Because
it's downward--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I like that.
OK, I like that.
OK so S, A, B, C,
D, E. So assume
this is the order that they
listed in adjacency list.
So let's label all of the edges.
SA and SB are what?
AUDIENCE: Forward edges.
PROFESSOR: OK AC?
AUDIENCE: Forward.
PROFESSOR: CD?
PROFESSOR: CE?
AUDIENCE: Forward.
PROFESSOR: OK, AE?
AUDIENCE: Aren't
those tree edges?
AUDIENCE: That's a forward edge.
PROFESSOR: That
took a while, guys.
That took a while.
AUDIENCE: It goes forward.
AUDIENCE: Well no,
forward means like you're
skipping a generation.
PROFESSOR: OK so
the three edges.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the three
edges are the ones
that DFS uses to go forward.
So they're the ones
that map the DFS calls.
So how do we express that?
So suppose you're at some node
u, and you have an edge, uv.
AUDIENCE: The parent of v is u.
PROFESSOR: So you're
at here, right now.
OK, so v.parent has to be u.
And?
v is?
Is it visited or not?
AUDIENCE: It's a new vertex.
AUDIENCE: It's not.
PROFESSOR: So v is
not visited yet.
So this is a tree edge.
Now let's compare this
to a forward edge.
So what happens
to a forward edge?
AUDIENCE: Parents of children--
AUDIENCE: Parent ancestors--
PROFESSOR: So you're
at here right now.
And you're looking
at the edge uv.
Right? so we're
looking at the edge uv.
uv would point
downward in the tree.
What's true about--
AUDIENCE: v.parent is u.
AUDIENCE: No--
AUDIENCE: Not necessarily.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So v.parent is u.
So it can be the parent,
or the grandparent,
or-- so u has to be
somewhere up the tree.
Right?
So I can have a ton
of dot parents here.
AUDIENCE: There has to be more
than one dot parent, right?
Because otherwise
we get tree edge.
It can't just be one parent.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So you'd have to
recurse up more than once.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So for a node you go up until
you find u, and if you found u,
then it's a forward
edge, otherwise,
if you find the root of
the tree then you give up.
AUDIENCE: Well then
it's a cross edge.
If you go up and you get
to the root but-- oh--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if
you got to the root,
it is not the forward edge.
Right now we're looking
at what does it mean.
So you have to be somewhere
around the ancestor chain of u,
so if you keep following v's
parents, you have to see u.
If not, it's not
the forward edge.
OK.
And when you see
it, did you visit it
or did you not visit it?
AUDIENCE: Already visited.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So now we have two more edge
types, we have back edges,
and we have cross edges.
Right?
Show me a back edge here.
AUDIENCE: DA.
PROFESSOR: DA is a back edge.
OK back edges are
also reasonably easy.
So let's do those.
What's a back edge.
So I am at u now.
I'm looking at the edge uv.
AUDIENCE: It's a cycle.
AUDIENCE: Node to ancestor.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's a
node to an ancestor.
PROFESSOR: OK so who
is who's ancestor?
AUDIENCE: A is D's ancestor.
AUDIENCE: V is u's ancestor.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if I keep going,
u.parent many times over,
I should eventually
see v. Uhh-- yeah.
So the difference
between this and this
is who is who's parent?
AUDIENCE: Wait, wouldn't
u be a parent of v?
Because we didn't go from
A to C to D and then at D
I realize that I
can go to A, but I
won't go because
it's already visited?
PROFESSOR: Wait.
AUDIENCE: But assuming that--
AUDIENCE: A is an ancestor of D.
PROFESSOR: So A is
an ancestor of D
because by the time
I got to D, I've
already set the parent
pointers for C and D.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But-- wait.
u.parent is v. Then u is
A here and v is D here--
AUDIENCE: No u is D here.
PROFESSOR: I'm at u
right now, so I'm at D.
And I'm looking at the edge uv.
AUDIENCE: Do we have
a cross edge in here?
PROFESSOR: Do we have
a cross edge in here.
Good question.
What is the cross edge?
AUDIENCE: C?
PROFESSOR: OK so this
guy is a cross edge.
So what is the difference
between a cross edge
and a forward edge?
[CLASS MURMURS]
AUDIENCE: It's not an ancestor.
AUDIENCE: Ancester goes up to S.
PROFESSOR: So a cross edge is
very close to a forward edge
except u is not an ancestor
of v. v in the DFS tree.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Yep.
So the only common ancestor
between B and C is the source.
OK so please get these
conditions in the notes.
So as a summary, if it's
an edge that DFS uses,
it's a tree edge.
If it's going against the way
of the DFS, it's a back edge.
If it fast forwards
in DFS, so instead
of going one level down, it
does multiple levels down,
then it's a forward edge.
And otherwise, it's weird
edge so it's a cross edge.
One way to look at it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this
only true because we
were going alphabetically?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this
depends on the order
in which the nodes are
listed in the adjacency list.
AUDIENCE: So it could've
been pretty different
if we went from A to E?
PROFESSOR: Oh Yeah, yeah.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying to
solve this another way.
The graph information--
PROFESSOR: Yeah
AUDIENCE: --would you say that's
moderate or an easy example?
The transformation.
PROFESSOR: This is
on the easy side.
So look at the problems
that we had so far.
There are more problems
in this review packet.
There are like six,
seven, eight problems.
It's going to be online.
It's the notes for
this recitation.
Sorry, bad name.
So the notes for
this recitation.
This is on the easy side.
The StarCraft problem, last time
is on the insanely difficult
side, so that's not
going to happen.
AUDIENCE: I so
don't even get that.
PROFESSOR: That's
on the hard side.